are you attempting to break up with me
do not see stuff human furniture I just
don't really love it and I want to go
explore TomTom we're good doesn't feel
[ __ ] good it's a little bit like what
if your dog said it wanted to go and
live with your neighbor instead of you
this is the old trusty pal this is the
thing you thought would always be there
so when that goes away that rocks you of
it hopefully we didn't go full method on
there throwing a bit of punishment in
there
[Music]
reg realm and you must be Oedipus right
Roger l is the CEO of Pierce media this
small blue blood more well-respected
also family-owned media conglomerates
stay have lunch oh my tummy is delicate
we really only eat Pulitzer over it
piers Holly Hunter it was the go-to
person for the rare role we all felt
like she could play the power and the
subtlety you know his character who
doesn't embody the same variety of power
but Logan does which is kind of the
bludgeon she's much more the subtle
knife the family knows what you're after
and they're not interested mm-hmm what
am i after you're playing your favorite
tune again now only this time I take it
some genius bankers convinced you that
the only way to keep the Jackals out is
to leverage yourself until you're too
big to take down there's not many people
who Logan finds interesting but someone
like that is interesting to him and so
they seen that possibility of a certain
mutual regard between them even if they
come from slightly different places on
behalf of the Pierce family and the
media organization it is privately owned
for a hundred and fifty years the
message would be a typically balanced -
nuanced an objective [ __ ] Logan's like
the shark that always keeps moving
forward 21 billion dollars the thing is
it's an emotional matter for the Pierces
21.5 Kendall is the same numbers it
doesn't fit with Logan's character to be
defeated so
some ways he can't be
you
[Music]
you